Joaquin Phoenix is back Owen Wilson is
back reese witherspoon is back but you
know what makes them all alike inherent
vice right off the bat Paul Thomas
Anderson is back a lot of people are
back in this movie I know it's good to
be back in black do-do-do-do-do-do now
if any of you are familiar with Paul
Thomas Anderson he's directed films like
Boogie Nights Magnolia punch-drunk love
there will be blood the master lately
his movies have been a bit meandering
less about linear plots and more about
peeking in on characters lives well they
do things until they stop doing them
which I love when it's done right now I
know I'm in the minority on this but I
haven't been in love with some of his
recent films there will be blood I
recognize why it's great but there's
something about it that leaves me cold I
just can't connect to it and not in the
way the filmmakers want me to not
connect to it in the butt then there's
the master which I find more emotionally
distant than there will be blood but I
enjoyed a little bit more just because I
like the 1950s aesthetics ass phenix
we've begun and now we have inherent
vice paul thomas anderson's new 1970s
themed stoner new our character study
based on her novel by thomas pynchon's
guys novels are supposed to be super
hard to adapt and I'm gonna be honest
with you right up front I really dubbed
this movie puppet arms it's a bunch of
different characters bumping into one
another all tied together with a quirky
little mystery and it's so much fun this
movie has a rhythm it has a beat the
mystery is a bit winding and confusing
but it's ultimately not the entire point
of the film the film noir aesthetic the
1970s mood and scenery the clever
writing and the great performance is
made
what he'll move and it all follows this
guy Larry doc Sportello played by
joaquin phoenix i would totally suck
what what's his name i would totally
suck joaquin phoenix's lift them i would
totally suck joaquin phoenix's hippie
dick Joaquin Phoenix has garnered a lot
of respect over these recently throwing
himself into roles and giving us great
in-depth performances I do you like a
black no I do you like her rap like
never Mike and once again he disappears
into this one he's a laid-back stone or
private detective but he has such
natural charm and charisma that he
blends in seamlessly with this movie you
kind of want to hang out with the guy in
the book and he's a great anchor to the
film and it's cool because he's not
super tough he's actually kind of you
know effeminate in certain ways which is
just need the rest of the cast is great
as well Josh Brolin Reese Witherspoon oh
and Wilson reminding me in this film
just how good an actor that guy can be
sometimes who really stood out hey
Joaquin Phoenix why don't you shave your
sideburns it's coming along joanna
newsom Catherine waterston Benicio del
Toro thought I was gonna say del taco
that's racist so shut up Martin Short
he's only in this movie for a couple
minutes but man is that guy entertaining
as hell to watch Eric Roberts even turns
in a powerful role in his short time in
the film i would suck the entire cast
collective dick the music by jonny
greenwood from Radiohead it's very
subtle but it complements the movie as a
piece the cinematography is great
especially in 70 millimeter it really
feels like an authentic 70s movie so
altogether I kind of loved it of all PT
Anderson's recent efforts I think this
one's my favorite it's totally off the
wall a film noir character piece and I
had a blast watching it it feels totally
authentic it's equal parts funny fun
intriguing and emotional so let me get
straight to the point here all in all i
gotta say paul thomas anderson and
inherent vice got it super duper big ass
sideburns right
all right guys why don't you go that
computer scroll down that comment box
below and tell me which movie detective
what you want to get stoned and have sex
with and last but not least if you want
to get updated every time a new review
or a video is out click this bump on my
dick to subscribe that's right the dick
and you know what they say about this
little vice the things that come out of
him are inherent to the fact that I'm a
man because that's how semen works